ungewissheit und große sorge in belarus
weiter ist unklar was genau mit der
oppositionspolitikerin kolesnikova
geschehen ist offenbar wurde sie vom
grenzschutz festgenommen streit um hilfe
für die autoindustrie vor dem gipfel im
kanzleramt fordert die csu
kaufprämien auch für benziner und diesel
von karl dem großen bis friedrich
barbarossa eine einmalige ausstellung
auf den spuren von 500 jahren deutscher
kaiser zeit
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen wir begrüßen
sie zur heute sendung an diesem
dienstagabend kristin otto ist auch hier
und sie hat nachher den sport sehr gerne
einen schönen programm wie machthaber
alexander lukaschenko in belarus mit der
demokratiebewegung in seinem land umgeht
darauf schauen inzwischen sehr viele
menschen sehr genau
nicht nur in belarus selbst gestern
verschwand die letzte führende
oppositionspolitikerin die noch bleiben
konnte im land das schicksal von maria
kohl s nikkor war völlig ungewiss heute
gibt es anzeichen dafür dass sie das
land verlassen sollte sich aber
geweigert hat doch es kursieren auch
andere versionen für begann gibt uns
einen überblick
ein auto nähert sich dem checkpoint an
der belarussische ukrainischen grenze
in ihm sollen maria callas in die koffer
und zwei weitere oppositionelle sitzen
was dann passiert ist nicht ganz klar
viele russische staatsmedien melden die
38-jährige habe illegal versucht die
grenze zu überqueren und sei
festgenommen worden
unterstützer von collison die koffer
berichten hingegen sie habe sich
geweigert belarus zu verlassen habe
ihren pass zerrissen und sei dann am
grenzübergang alexandrowka festgenommen
worden
gestützt wird diese version der
geschichte von offiziellen ukrainischen
stimmen mit maria callas nicole hat mit
einer mutigen aktion die belarussischen
spezialkräfte daran gehindert sie auf
das territorium der ukraine zu
vertreiben
zwei weitere oppositionsmitglieder
wurden gewaltsam aus belarus ausgewiesen
maria callas in die koffer war gestern
morgen mitten in minsk verschleppt
worden nun hat sie sich wohl mit letzten
mitteln gegen eine abschiebung gewehrt
es war bekannt dass sie gestern entführt
wurde heute sollen sie angeblich
versucht haben die grenze zu
durchbrechen
das ist einfach lächerlich sie wollten
als ich heute gelesen habe dass sie
ihren pass zerrissen hat habe ich so
einen respekt bekommen
ich bin sehr dankbar dass sie kämpft
collison die covers mitstreiterin und
präsidentschaftskandidatin svetlana turn
of skye musste bereits aus belarus
flüchten den europarat bat sie heute per
videoschalte um mehr internationalen
druck auf lukaschenko
wir brauchen sanktionen gegen personen
die kriminelle aufträge erteilen und
ausführen die gegen internationale
normen und menschenrechte verstoßen
der druck auf die opposition nimmt zu in
minsk wollen sie trotzdem am abend
wieder auf die straße für maria
kalashnikova ja da gibt es noch viele
fragen für begangen und nahmen nach
moskau viel verwirrung heute den ganzen
tag es gibt kein bild heute keinen
einzigen ton von calexico war eine
oppositionspolitikerin die in der
öffentlichkeit stand wie viel sorge muss
sich die welt jetzt um sie machen also
bilder russische menschenrechts
organisationen die die methoden des
regimes lukaschenko ja schon lange
kennen und kritisieren die gehen davon
aus dass die lage ernst ist und sie
haben sich an die un gewand an die
arbeitsgruppe die sich mit dem
erzwungenen verschwindenlassen von
menschen beschäftigt die bälle
russischen grenzschutzbehörden die sagen
zwar sie haben maria callas in die
koffer kurzzeitig festgenommen
inhaftiert haben wollen sie sie aber
nicht die genauen umstände der nacht
darüber schweigen sie weiterhin
zuletzt war es der mitarbeiterstab von
victor barcot für den ja auch maria
callas in die koffer gearbeitet hat der
aus nicht näher genannten quellen
informationen bekommen hatte dass sich
die oppositionelle in der grenzregion
gommel befinden sollte in gewahrsam der
dortigen grenzschutzbehörden daraufhin
wurde ein anwalt kontaktiert der es
wiederum sollte kontakt zur kalaschnikow
aufnehmen um ihr rechtlichen
juristischen beistand zu gewähren als er
dann die behörden wiederum kontaktierte
hieß es hier ist calcio war auch nicht
das heißt auch über 30 stunden nach dem
verschwinden der oppositionellen geht
die suche nach ihrem aufenthaltsort
weiter für begann moskau
herzlichen dank und damit zu uns nach
deutschland die wichtigste deutsche
industrie hat große sorgen
und es gibt neue diskussionen darum wie
ihr geholfen werden
heute abend ist autogipfel
bundesregierung ministerpräsidenten und
autoindustrie reden miteinander weil in
der politik die angst umgeht vor einem
absturz der deutschen schlüsselbranche
gucken uns das mal ein bisschen genauer
an zulieferfirmen eingeschlossen
arbeiten hier mehr als 830.000 menschen
in der deutschen autoindustrie und die
hat enorme schwierigkeiten im ersten
halbjahr wurden gut ein drittel weniger
neuwagen zugelassen als zur gleichen
zeit im vorjahr
das problem ist aber nicht nur die krone
ab handle me die autobranche muss sich
auch strukturell umstellen bei der
e-mobilität und bei der digitalisierung
simon pfanzelt berichtet gleich am
morgen setzt markus söder den ton die
kriselnde deutsche auto industrie
brauche hilfe so die botschaft des csu
chefs im morgenmagazin seine partei
sympathisiert dabei mit einer kaufprämie
auch für autos mit verbrennungsmotor
klar ist aus meiner sicht wir müssen
etwas tun um am ende viele arbeitsplätze
und tatsächlich einen kernbereich unter
industrie zu unterstützen
dabei sollte es heute eigentlich um das
auto von morgen gehen was macht die e
mobilität wie gelingt autonomes fahren
doch diese debatte wird überschattet von
einer frage wie kommt die autoindustrie
aus der korona misere
was allerdings ein sinnloser einsatz von
geld wäre
wer eine kaufprämie für verbrenner denn
das bedeutet man investiert in die
vergangenheit und nicht in die zukunft
und die autoindustrie braucht
investitionen in die zukunft es geht um
die zukunft einer industrie die schon
vor corona im umbruch war weg vom
verbrenner hin zu alternativen antrieben
laut wirtschaftsexperten braucht es da
nicht in erster linie geldspritzen
sondern schlaue innovation
am ende gehört es nun mal ganz nüchtern
betrachtet zum strukturwandel dazu dass
dinge die nicht mehr gewünscht werden
dann einfach nicht mehr produziert
werden können
und entweder schaffen die unternehmen
eine neue idee der staat wird sie ihnen
für sich genommen nicht erklären können
und nicht bieten können der muss nur
gute rahmenbedingungen dafür schaffen
aber der strukturwandel muss in der
marktwirtschaft von den unternehmen
bewältigt werden
im gespräch zwischen politik und
industrie geht es um geld
aber auch darum was die richtigen
rezepte sind für die mobilität der
zukunft bringen wir heute theo koll mit
dazu in die sendung guten abend eine
prämie also auch für verbrennungsmotoren
eine kaufprämie ist wieder im gespräch
wie stehen denn die chancen dass die
tatsächlich kommt nur wer ehrlich zu
sein wenn die prämien rennpferd wäre
würde ich nicht allzu viel darauf wetten
die koalition hat sich ja schon klar
dagegen ausgesprochen und die kanzlerin
hat einer solchen prämie vor kurzem noch
einmal ausdrücklich eine absage erteilt
da die csu jetzt so massiv politisch gas
gibt für eine prämie für
verbrennungsmotoren könnte das thema
heute abend dann doch noch einmal
besprochen werden obwohl es so weit ich
erfahren habe weder auf der tagesordnung
steht noch sich im vorbereiteten
ergebnis papier findet im kern geht es
heute abend eher um konzepte zur
stärkung der zukunftsfähigkeit der
autoindustrie und das heißt
beispielsweise mehr tempo zu machen
bei der entwicklung einer
ladeinfrastruktur und es geht um den
künftigen einsatz alternativer
kraftstoffe vor allem aber soll
deutschland künftig eine führungsrolle
beim autonomen fahren übernehmen das
ambitionierte ziel lautet offensichtlich
deutschland soll das erste land weltweit
seien das fahrerlose autos im
regelbetrieb und landesweit erlaubt also
weiterhin gilt die autoindustrie soll
bitte schön nach vorne schauen
interessanter abend vielen dank für
diese informationen live aus berlin tu
und noch eine branche die große probleme
meldet auch für hotels restaurants und
clubs war das corona ja bis jetzt ein
desaster
sie hätten die krise als erste ab
bekommen klagt ihr verband und sie
würden wohl auch am längsten darunter
leiden besonders hart habe es hotels und
restaurants in den städten getroffen
katastrophal sei die lage auch bei klubs
und eventcatering insgesamt ist die rede
von 17,6 milliarden euro umsatzverlust
allein bis ende juni
und noch eine zahl die zeigt worum es
hier geht laut verband sind in der
angeschlagenen branche 2,4 millionen
beschäftigt mehr von roman lescaut war
eigentlich der september buchungs
stärkster monat im berliner hotel war
doch dieses jahr sind kaum gäste da die
funkausstellung auf sparflamme
der marathon abgesagt die acht
angestellten in dem kleinen haus bleiben
alle in kurzarbeit die lage schwierig
wenn ich zu sagen wir haben
umsatzeinbrüche von über 80 und vor
allem haben wir keine perspektive wie es
weitergeht
die dehoga umfrage zeichnet ein düsteres
bild insgesamt weist die hotellerie nach
jahren des wachstums im ersten halbjahr
einen rekordverlust aus - 48,2 prozent
die situation in ballungsräumen
besorgniserregend in den großstädten
bricht der internationale tourismus
zusammen großveranstaltungen sind nach
wie vor nicht zulassen
sportveranstaltungen nicht events nicht
also alles das womit auch wir unser geld
verdienen können kaum besser die lage in
der gastronomie für restaurants und
hotels liegen laut dehoga die
umsatzverluste zwischen märz und juni
bei 17,6 milliarden euro
die branche warnt unterstützung an
nachbesserungen bei überbrückungshilfen
etwa oder corona bedingte veränderungen
wir brauchen weitere hilfen für die
wirtschaft und auch für das gastgewerbe
ansonsten droht eine große existenznot
in den unternehmen und am ende eine
insolvenzwelle die uns möglicherweise
zum winter hin erreichen würde
weitere unterstützung wie sie in der
städtischen hotellerie besonders
dringend erscheint anders als in
klassischen ferienorten gab es im hotel
war ii auch in den sommermonaten kaum
gäste im zentrum der korona bekämpfung
stehen von anfang an die
gesundheitsämter ebenso von anfang an
ist klar viele ämter sind damit komplett
überlastet
bund und länder wollen vier milliarden
euro in den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst stecken die kommunen
dringen darauf dass das schnell passiert
und das ist nicht das einzige problem
das auf einer konferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin heute auf den tisch kam
andrea maurer
seit monaten kämpfen sie im
gesundheitsamt wiesbaden gegen die
pandemie kontakte nachverfolgen
quarantäne verordnen tests durchführen
im vergleich zu anderen ämtern seien sie
noch relativ gut durch die krise
gekommen sagt die leiterin
aber auch sie hoffen hier auf hilfe aus
der politik natürlich für uns möglichst
schnell weil wir müssen ja darauf
reagieren können wir müssen flexibel
handhaben können die dinge die pandemie
erfordert das und ja bis dahin wie
gesagt immer die bevölkerung bitten
bestmöglich mitzumachen
gesundheitsdienste in not in einer
webkonferenz suchte die kanzlerin heute
den austausch mit ämtern und kommunen
wir haben einen ganz wesentlichen anteil
daran dass wir das infektionsgeschehen
bislang in deutschland noch weitgehend
unter kontrolle halten konnten werden
die bullen viel geld in die hand nehmen
weil wir wissen dass nicht nur
individualmedizin in unserem land gut
sein muss sondern auch die community
medizin wie man so sagt für die
gemeinschaft ein pakt für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst stellt
jetzt vier milliarden euro in aussicht
800 millionen davon für digitalisierung
bis ende 2022 sind außerdem 5000 neue
stellen geplant zu spät sagen kritiker
vor monaten hätte man das gebraucht denn
auch so langsam sind die
gesundheitsämter ja schon erschöpft und
den nächsten monaten werden wir von dem
pakt nichts haben somit die wirkliche
kritische phase der pandemie hat der
pakt verpasst in der anerkennung für die
gesundheitsdienste sind sich alle einig
die dienste selbst werden die politik
nun wohl auch an ihrem versprechen
messen und daran wie schnell die
zugesagte hilfe kommt die zahl der
gemeldeten neuinfektionen geht in
deutschland im moment leicht nach oben
im schnitt der vergangenen woche wurden
täglich 1260 neuinfektionen gemeldet das
sind 60 mehr als gestern
im vergleich dazu dramatisch ist die
entwicklung in frankreich im sieben tage
schnitt infizieren sich dort aktuell
täglich 6880 menschen
es gibt auch immer mehr schwer
betroffene regionen 28 von 100
departements stuft die französische
regierung als risikogebiete 1
das virus ist zurück in den
krankenhäusern rund um marseille auf
dieser intensivstation sind acht von
zehn betten mit corona patienten belegt
alle sind erst seit kurzem hier
wir haben viel dazugelernt bei der
behandlung dieser patienten aber in den
letzten 15 tagen ist die zahl
exponentiell angestiegen
und das konnte uns ans limit bringen
eine situation die auch alle anderen
krankenhäuser der region betrifft ein
vorbote in ganz frankreich steigen die
infektionen rasant die regierung ist
besorgt
incity das virus zirkuliert es gibt
täglich tausende neue fälle
das ist viel ja das ist beunruhigend vor
den teststationen lange schlangen
wartezeit bis zu fünf stunden masken
gehören jetzt zum alltag in ganz
frankreich sie sind pflicht am
arbeitsplatz in vielen städten zum
beispiel in paris müssen sie auch
draußen getragen werden im job trage ich
sie acht stunden pro tag es wäre super
wenn ich sie aussehen könnte
erst dieses masken nützen nichts weil es
keine gab und jetzt müssen wir sie
tragen das ist verwirrend
den grund für die aktuelle situation
sehen experten vor allem in der
zögerlichen einführung der masken
pflicht man hat diese pflicht zu spät in
geschlossenen räumen eingeführt
frankreich hat sich lange zeit damit
begnügt zu testen und zu isolieren
aber diese epidemie kann man nicht nur
mit testen unter kontrolle bringen
jetzt gilt das prinzip hoffnung dass die
strengeren regeln doch noch greifen und
die corinna zahlen wieder sinken und
beunruhigende zahlen auch aus spanien
das land meldet inzwischen mehr als
500.000 bestätigte corona infektionen so
viele wie in keinem anderen land in
westeuropa so viel zu diesem thema
zunächst und jetzt neues vom brh exit
großbritannien ist ja seit januar kein
eu-mitglied mehr seitdem gilt eine
übergangsphase wie die beziehungen
kommendes jahr aussehen sollen darüber
verhandeln eu und london seit heute
wieder
allerdings will der britische premier
boris johnson bereits gültige
vereinbarungen ändern auch wenn das
internationales recht verletzt
das hat seine regierung jetzt bestätigt
in deutschland bekommen hartz 4
empfänger im nächsten jahr mehr geld als
geplant der regelsatz für alleinstehende
erwachsene steigt um 14 euro auf 446
euro im monat
den größten sprung gibt es für
jugendliche zwischen 14 und 17
nämlich 45 euro mehr im monat das macht
373 euro
in deutschland werden immer mehr
illegale drogen konsumiert seit neun
jahren steigt die zahl der von der
polizei erfassten straftaten im letzten
jahr auf fast 360.000 das
bundeskriminalamt führt die wachsen
den zahlen auf eine erfolgreiche
fahndung zurück aber eben auch auf
zunehmenden konsum
den größten anstieg gab es beim kokain
das laut bka keine elite droge mehr ist
gut zwölf prozent mehr registrierte
delikte so jetzt was ganz anderes in der
sendung eine sehenswerte ausstellung mit
wuchtigem nahmen die kaiser und die
säulen ihrer macht im mittelpunkt kaiser
persönlichkeiten die über jahrhunderte
die geschicke von halb europa bestimmt
haben karl der große etwa oder friedrich
barbarossa wie kamen sie zu ihrer
unglaublichen macht ging auch damals
vieles nur mit beziehungen
all das zeigt die schau im landesmuseum
mainz mit überaus wertvollen exponaten
marion geiger 700 jahre alt und eines
der wertvollsten bücher der welt mit 80
millionen euro versichert der codex
manesse die umfangreichste sammlung
mittelhochdeutscher literatur
ohne ihn wären viele bilder und lieder
des mittelalters verloren
nach zehn jahren im tresor ist er nun
wieder zu sehen eine rare gelegenheit in
mainz in der ausstellung die kaiser und
die säulen ihrer macht den besucher
erwarten hier exponate aus dem in und
ausland dieses in dieser
zusammenstellung noch nie gegeben hat
es entsteht hier eine ganz einzigartige
welt an mittelalterlichen exponaten wo
der besucher auch mal die aura des
originals erleben kann und
dementsprechend das mittelalter noch mal
von einem ganz anderen blickwinkel sehen
kann
an der spitze der mittelalterlichen welt
steht der kaiser erst vom papst gesalbt
und doch ist seine macht brüchig denn er
braucht die zustimmung von bischöfen
fürsten rittern und städten
er muss seine netzwerke pflegen
mittelalterlichen kaiser mussten ständig
in ihrem reich umherziehen es ist ein
reich ohne hauptstadt und überall vor
ort treffen sie sich es ist also eine
präsenz gesellschaft man blickt sich in
die augen
man kommt oder man kommt auch nicht und
man handelt die dinge die wichtig sind
aus in persönlichen begegnungen ab 1356
regelt die goldene bulle die wahl des
königs und künftigen kaisers eine
friedensordnung die 450 jahre bestand
hat zwei von sieben erhaltenen
originalen sind in mainz ausgestellt im
landesmuseum bis april nächsten jahres
so und dann guckt man in der sendung auf
den sport allerdings christian muss man
sagen auch da hat das virus so sehr es
dauert leider überall bei tour de france
chef christian prudhomme war der
obligatorische test auf eine krone
infektion positiv er muss sich nun für
eine woche zurück ziehen alle profis
waren dagegen negativ und konnten nach
dem ruhetag die zehnte etappe in angriff
nehmen gegen den wind lautet heute das
motto bei dieser knapp 170 kilometer
langen etappe die größtenteils direkt an
der atlantikküste entlang führt gut 15
kilometer vor dem ziel deutet alles auf
einen massenspurt hin
die teams mit den starken sprintern in
ihren reihen formieren sich derweil der
mann mit den schnellsten beinen heute an
ihre sam bennett vom team quick step für
den 29 jährigen erfüllt sich mit seinem
ersten etappensieg bei der tour ein
lebenstraum
zudem sichert er sich das grüne trikot
des besten sprinters
erfreulich aus deutscher sicht der
sechste platz von andré greipel und
weiterhin im gelben trikot des
gesamtführenden der slowene primoz
rupitsch weiterer prominenter kroner
fall beim französischen champions league
finalisten paris langsamer als siebter
profis kilian im pub positiv getestet
wurden beim gestrigen training mit
frankreichs nationalmannschaft war der
stürmerstar noch guter dinge und nicht
ahnend dass er sich das nations league
duell gegen kroatien heute abend vom
sofa aus anschauen und rückschlag für
die deutschen u 21 fußballer auf dem weg
richtung em qualifikation sie verloren
das vorentscheidende spiel in belgien
eins zu vier die partien läufe nimmt
keinen guten lauf notbremse des
bielefelders pipa gegen dopende
platzverweis nach 18 minuten den
freistoss zirkelt enderli chemie über
die mauer feiner führungstreffer für
belgien nicht ganz unhaltbar dieser
zupfer von peters an schlotterbeck
bringt deutschland zurück elfmeter lukas
metzler der in belgien spielt der
ausgleich 31 minute kurz nach der pause
der kette lage ist so frei und schließt
dollar 221 kriens 3 zu 1 5 meter getoppt
von einer schönen kombination 71 minute
zum 4 2 1 1 stand eine bittere lektion
für die dezimierte kunst bitte schön
aber drei spiele gibt's ja noch zum
glück danke dir viel sonne im süden aber
der norden ist ein bisschen wolkiger
mehr gleich von ostend ali beim wetter
dann empfehle ich ihnen das heute
journal mit der kollegin bettina
schausten um 21.45 und möglicherweise
ersten ergebnissen des auto gipfels im
kanzleramt
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da und
wünschen ihnen allen einen angenehmen
haben
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hoher luftdruck
bestimmt das wetter vor allem in der
mitte und im süden europas aber im
norden da zieht ein tief durch und
bringt die kaltfront in unserer nähe
so überquerte teil norddeutschlands
morgen im tagesverlauf aber bereits in
der nacht sind hier schon wolken
unterwegs und es gibt etwas regen der
ost west sonst lockert es auf im süden
da bildet sich teils dichter nebel bei
temperaturen von 10 bis 7 grad und
milden 17 grad an der nordsee morgen
tagesverlauf bleibt die zweiteilung
hauptsächlich im norden viele wolken und
hier ist auch etwas regen dabei
ansonsten nach süden hin wieder
sonnenschein pur vor allem an den alpen
und das bei temperaturen bis 29 grad im
südwesten
es wird richtig warm hier aber auch 26
grad zum beispiel einen ice so am
kühlsten mit 19 grad richtung schleswig
holstein die nächsten tage
am donnerstag bleibt es trocken bei 17
bis 25 grad und ab freitag bleibt es
weiterhin warm und überwiegend sonnig
bei 18 bis 28 grad damit ein schöner
abend